Ich war damals S1, S2, S3, S5, im Stab des Jägerbataillons 4, Dienstgrad Leutnant.
Am 21. August als der Einmarsch der russischen Truppen erfolgte
war ich nicht in der Garnison, sondern auf Bergführergehilfekurs.
Es wurde damals beim Kurs beraten ob der Kurs abgebrochen werden sollte.
Nein, es wurden nur einzelne Personen, darunter ich, rückgerufen.
Als ich zurück kam traf ich mein Bataillon in einem Verfügungsraum,
Ortsunterkunft in Wolkersdorf an.
Das Bataillon hatte den Auftrag die Brünner Straße im Ernstfall zu sperren.
Es konnten aber keine technischen Vorbereitungen getroffen werden,
weil es kein offizieller Einsatz war, sondern nur eine Verstärkung der Grenzgarnisonen.
Wir waren dort sehr behindert durch Wildzäune und Betretungsverbote.
Die Stimmung war sehr schlecht da die Bevölkerung uns wirklich nicht sehr ernst nahm,
sie fragte was wir so weit hinter der Grenze überhaupt tun,
warum wir hier sozusagen nicht in der Etappe herumkugeln.
Die Maßnahmen die ich getroffen habe war einmal
die Erkundung der Sperre der Bundesstraße 7 noch zu intensivieren
und mit Hilfe eines Milizoffiziers, der über Baumaschinen verfügte
im Raum Wolkersdorf, trafen wir alle Vorbereitungen, wenn es zu einem Übergriff gekommen wäre,
wären innerhalb kurzer Zeit zumindest Regelstellungen an der Bundesstraße 7 ausgebaut worden.
Eines Tages erschien überraschend der Bundesminister, es kam zu einem Treffen an der Bundesstraße 7
und mein Bataillonskommandant stellte dem Bundesminister die denkwürdige Frage:
"Du, Herr Bundesminister, was machen wir wenn die Russen wirklich kommen?"
Die erstaunliche Antwort: "Gebt ein paar Schüsse ab und dann haut ab."
Für mich als junger Leutnant der etwas mehr an taktischen Befehlen erwartet hätte, etwas überraschend.